sag uns was erwarten die menschen jetzt
heute von den eu staatschefs der liebe
nele sie menschen hier in linz schauen
sie sich stunde eher darauf was in ihrer
stadt passiert denn die angst fährt
offenbar zurückgestellt deutsche morgen
neue festnahmen gegeben das erste mal
seit vielen tagen das ist bei einer
demonstration vor einer fabrik passiert
man weiß noch nicht genau was mit den
menschen passiert ist aber die angst ist
hier dass lukaschenko zurückschlagen
könnte und ich stehe hier mit drei
aktivistinnen und mit einem eimer zu
sitzen
maria tatjana und maria sind sie angst
haben sie angst dass die gewalt hier
zurückkommen könnte maria sagt die
menschen haben große angst vor
und auch lukas von angst und setzen
deshalb reagiert er so tatjana wurde das
jubiläum am jura demonstriert und
streetpass days of things change that
lukas schenkel strikes back haben sie
angst
da diana dass lukaschenko hier genauso
wieder gewalt anwenden können so wie in
der letzten woche
die einzige chance dass sie hier auch
die straße gehen und für freiheit
demonstrieren aber natürlich haben wir
angst und jetzt rechne ich mit ohne
connect hat
lange in deutschland gelebt in bayern
oder heute gibt es einen eu rat in
brüssel
was erwartest du von dem was erwarten
sie von den politikern in deutschland
und in der eu was das durch das sagt an
deutlich und klar dass diese sie
existieren diese mehr als dass sie das
system hinter all dem folgt die leute
sind getötet gibt blumen und was soll
was sollte die eu genau tun aus ihrer
sicht die sagen lukas schenk und nicht
mehr anerkannt als präsident richtig sie
muss sagen möglichkeit situation zu
lösen und sie stehen hinter diesen rat
und unterstützung
vielen dank vielen dank herr maria
vielen dank sagt jana das sind 73 von
tausenden den tausenden 100.000 menschen
die hier mutiger auf die straße gehen
und obwohl es heute festnahmen gegeben
hat sagen sie wir machen weiter heute
abend in der neue test geplant und auch
in den nächsten tagen wird es
weitergehen